e
uh hour being 10 o'clock I'd like to
open our meeting long range Capital
planning utilization
committee uh welcome all of you here
today to Public Works and highways uh
first first item is acceptive minutes of
April 12
20124 uh as they've been distributed
does anyone see any corrections or
admissions
seeing none approve motion to approve
second um
discussion all those in favor signify by
saying I I any
opposed no
exensions Miss person um looks to be
unanimous old business there's none uh
um 2417 depart dep Transportation
requests authorization to sell 65 an
acre state owned land located norly side
of New Hampshire route 101 in the town
of Milford and presenting for the
Department
please thank you Mr chairman Steve
leonte within New Hampshire Department
of Transportation as you just mentioned
the department seeks authorization to
sell approximately 1.65 acres of
state-owned land located in Northerly
side of Route 101 in the town of Milford
to the the town of Milford and assess an
an additional
$1,100 um administrative fee the town of
Milford proposes to construct a pump
station um an access drive to uh provide
Town water from the pachuk Water Works
the parcel is a portion of a larger 1.23
acre parcel acquired in
1969 for the Milford Amherst project
apartment acquired the property for
approximately oh for 34 $4,000 at the
time the the property had a residential
building of one one and a half story
Colonial House and two sheds that were
demolished as part of the
project conditions of the sale will be
that the town will will commission to
license land surve
to um create a boundary um boundary plan
survey uh illustrating the existing
right of way the town will be required
to also obtain all local and state Lane
use approval
uh staff
appraiser apprais the property and
assess the value as of March 19th
$169,400 thank you other questions Mr
lonte move to approve second motion made
to approve and seconded uh further
discussion should we go a roll call on
this have
so motion's been made and seconded
there's no question if you're in favor
of the motion uh item number
017 signified by saying I I any opposed
passes unanimously thank you um I'd like
to combine they're in the same location
item 20 and 21 requests renewal of land
lease Capital Hotel company partial
state land owned consisting of
9,78 sare ft the second 121 is
13,430 square ft near the intersection
93 exit2 and with that sir
please thank you Mr chairman as you just
mentioned the department seeks
authorization to renew a land lease of
Turnpike owned property um the two
leases are combined uh area of it will
be a combined annual rent of
$22,000 uh plus the the $1,100
administrative fee for each lease uh the
conditions of the sale will be um that
there'll be no access to 93 or 3A direct
access to 93 or 3A lease will be subject
to revocation if the department ever
needs the property back for Highway
purposes um and the leased area will be
used for
exclusive will be ex used exclusively
for hotel and restaurant parking um the
property was um is is made up of two
different Parcels uh and was con was
acquired for the uh B conquered uh
project to build part of the central New
Hampshire Turnpike system uh it was
first the first parcel was acquired in
1955 for $99,950
and the second parcel was acquired um
and the first parcel made up
11.41 Acres the second parcel was
acquired in 1956 and made up 1.5 Acres
where and um it was acquired for
$4,000 uh a staff appraiser appraised
the value of the property and concluded
that it was a uh the rent area was for
$92,000
or actually no $22,000 combined thank
24-21 motion been made and seconded any
questions before we call the
role seeing none if you are in favor of
item 20 and
21 um signify by saying I I I I if
you're opposed nay
um motion carries
unanimously I would like to move to item
number 25 Department of Transportation
requests authorization to sell 0.25
acres of state-owned land located on the
westly side of New Hampshire route 101
in the town of Milford proposed Charles
Simpson and louan PO for $20,500 if you
would sir thank you Mr chairman um as
you just mentioned we're seeking to uh
to sell 0.25 Acres of state owned land
in Milford on the Westerly side of Route
101 uh the parcel the subject parcel is
a portion of a larger 63 acre parcel
acquired in
1975 uh the department acquired the lot
for
$967 the improvements were removed as
part of the as part of the um the
Milford project uh the specific
conditions that the the sale will be
subject to is the buyer will uh be
required to commission a license land
surveyor to prepare a perimeter boundary
SE plan um illustrating the existing
right of way the buyer sh is also
responsible for all local and state land
use approvals a staff appraiser appraise
the property as contributory value and
as of March 22nd
2024 assess the value to be $20,500
uh the property was also offered to the
town of Milford pursuing to for uh Fort
col 39c and to the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority pursuant to RSA
204d colon 2 and uh both
declined move to approve item
24-25 motion made to approve second for
item 25 motion's been made and seconded
any
discussion if you're in favor of the
motion for item number 25 signified by
saying I I any opposed motion carries
unanimous if we will move to item number
26 Department of Transportation
authorized to sell 1.75 Acres of state
owned land located at 55 North Road Town
of Conway proposed sale town of Conway
for 175 ,000 there's also a request to
wave $1,100 Administration fees if you
would
sir thank you Mr chairman Department
seeks authorization to sell 1.75 Acres
of state owned land located at 55 North
Road in the town of Conway for
$175,000 uh the T at the town's
requests the department is also asking
the committee to wave the $1,100
administrative Fe
um in 197 the department um parcel was
acquired in
1972 via warranty deed from Liam balduck
for
$7,500 uh the department was acquired
for the construction of a patrol shed
and um which is depicted on the attached
plan the salt salt shed has since been
removed uh the subject conditions of the
sale is that uh the town will be
responsible for
uh obtaining all local and state land
use approvals the town will be U made
aware of any Federal Aviation
notification requirements for any
further construction because of its
proximity to local airports um the
property was valued by the staff
appraiser as of February 9 2024 to be
$175,000 a little more history behind
the the partiel um the town is likely to
convey this to a nonprofit organization
that will be using it as part of the
restoration of the flying Yankee which
is a streamlined locomotive currently
owned by the department of New Hampshire
and is going to be conveyed to that in
the process of being conveyed to that
entity who will then restore it for
public uh use so I can answer any
questions thank you yes please represent
Pro excuse me Senator PE so what's the
story behind the request to wave the
$1,100 fee the town asked us to wave the
$1,100 fee they didn't provide a
compelling reason why we should well I
think the idea is that it's going to go
to public use there is some so this this
parcel is very confusing if you've ever
looked at the deed the way the deed was
than so what occurred is that a deed was
written back in the 70s well the
original
deed describes the property next to the
property so uh an abstractor going
through and actually reading the deed
would be thinking that the deed is
conveying the property next door when
actually it ends and says the property
right next to this so that created some
confusion as to
ownership um the the town auctioned off
the property then it was determined that
it was actually State Property um being
used by one of our Patrol uh Highway
Maintenance uh sheds um for storage of
you know fill and gravel and any of that
stuff um so when that occurred we went
through the the Surplus property to see
if there were other areas let's face it
we own a lot of property in Conway so
there was a chance we can find another
property and and let this and knowing
what the use was for it it still
Transportation related that we went
ahead and started looking at this sale
so they already have the money from from
the auction to pay for this but they
haven't appropriated the $1,100
administrative fee Senator Lang knowing
that the $1,100 will just go back to the
local taxpayer and they'll have to pay
it I'm fine with waving the fee and
recommend we uh move to approve 242
second motion's been made and seconded
to approve item
26 uh further
discussion seeing none if you're in
favor of the motion please signify by
saying I or yes I I and anyone oppose no
uh motion carries
unanimously we will go to item 27
Department of Transportation request
continue approval of disposal of
approximately 2.75 Acres state owned
land along with improve movements
located at 592 Eaton Road in town of
Conway earing a one-year listing
agreement uh proposed sale of
$150,000 if you would
sir thank you Mr chairman again this is
a uh this is a renewal of or we're
looking to this is a a property that we
brought before this committee almost two
years ago and uh the property was listed
at that time for
$200,000 it's located next to one of our
salt sheds it was bought as um back in
2006 it was 3.5 acres and
um it it has a residential dwelling on
it the department is going to
maintain I believe it's
2.5 acres or Department uh 75 Acres uh
the Department's going to make retain
because of it has a uh has one of its
maintenance sheds right next door to it
so we because it had a dwelling on it
because of the market at the time we
listed it for 200,000 although we had
plenty of people have interest in it and
came through none of them were willing
to take it on it's been vacant I believe
since the time we purchased it um and at
the time we purchased it the surrounding
area was all vacant wooded land
now the surrounding area or a good
portion of the surrounding area is a
Highway Maintenance shed so it just
makes it less desirable to somebody
looking to Market it even if they're
they're looking to flip it so we went
ahead and and sent out the marketing
analysis to our local Realtors up there
in region one and um our own opinion
came back at 138,000 looking at the
marketing analysis we went with Janet
McMahon of redstone realy
and uh who who proposed a price of
150,000 looking at her analysis she seem
to to fit what our goals for so thank
you questions move to approve
24027 uh motion's been made to approve
second seconded a motion first and
second um dispos of approximately 2.75
Acres of state owned land along with
improvements located at 592 eat Road I I
must say when I drive by I think that's
a magnificent looking facility I'd buy
next door so but but yeah but I'm but
I'm also a contractor so uh if you're if
you're in favor of that motion signified
by saying I I I any opposed motion
carries
unanimous thank you for your
time we'll move to item 22 Department of
Natural and cultural resources requests
approval to sell approximately 30 acres
of land located on the north side of
conquer known as the Allen State Forest
$132,000
morning just push the button now you can
hear me uh my name is Patrick Hackley
I'm the director for the division of
forest and lands part of the Department
of Natural and cultural
resources so U it's fairly
straightforward like the other
transactions uh the department is
seeking the approval to dispose of a
state property known as Allen State
Forest uh it's about 30 acre parcel due
to the parcel's inherently difficult
access and small size uh the forest is
just not economically viable working
forest for us we we have done a forest
management operation on that several
years ago we don't intend to go back in
there if we were to hold on to it for
probably another 30 to 40 years um so we
desire to sell it on the Open Market at
fair market value as determined by a
recent appraisal um we have had interest
from an adjacent landowner to purchase
it at that appraised value and because
we've been trying to dispose of this
parcel for four or five years we felt
like it was most effective and efficient
to um work with the abing landowner at
the appraised value so um it was
appraised at$
129,000 um along with the $1,100
administrative fee uh it would it would
go to uh David Price senior and David
Price Jr for 132,000
thank you uh
questions
approve motion's been made to approve
item
22 uh and seconded any further
discussion seeing none if you're in
favor of the motion for item 22
signified by saying I I if you're
opposed nay thank you thank you Patrick
if I if I could I had the commissioner
in here at the earlier meeting we've
spoke about that par and oy near 25 and
16 and I know that we're going to be
together at the
oy Natural Area meeting Natural Area can
pull that together uh I'm hoping that we
can have a further discussion on that at
that point yes because the state police
are have marked the road out there and
they won't let boats Park out there so
and it has to do with the parking
congestion there it's really to extend
the parking area into the state forest I
think is that the proposal that's our
hope yep okay thank you sir you back
thank you we'll move to item 18
Department of Transportation requests an
authorization to Grand Eastman
approximately 52,000 square fet of
railroad property located on the state
Ed conquered Lincoln railroad Corridor
in lonia city of
lonia for 0 based on previous realized
and anticipated the access
administration fee of
$1,100 uh which the department receipt
subject to
changes L please good morning chairman
makoni members of the committee my name
is Lou Barker I am the railroad planner
and property manager for the Department
of trans transportations Bureau of rail
and
Transit thank you for hearing this this
is a a fun one for me because this is a
location of significant drainage
problems and uh a situation where we're
going work together with the city of
lonia
um the location is uh City street pus
Park Road which runs parallel to the
railroad
and it was actually built on an e
uh on a on a stretch of property
that individual Lots own and people
would have rights away over the lots to
their uh
camps well as years went by the city
took over the maintenance of this uh
Street and improved it and which way did
they go toward the
railroad however as um encumbering as
that sounds they also put in drainage
and they maintain that drainage that
drainage takes um drainage sorry for
using the word drainage so many times
but the drainage from the rail road goes
right into the drainage for the uh pus
Park Road so the two uh the bureau
Transit the railroad operator and the
City of Lone have been historically
trying to figure out who's going to be
maintaining the drainage so in part and
parcel this easement would be
reconciliation of those three factors
and a better uh maintenance program
through the city's
offices because we Grant basically grant
them imperity access to that stretch of
the railroad
property
um okay do you have any other questions
um I'd be glad to uh answer them any
questions Mr berer motion's been made to
approve
seconded by Pearl um further discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion of 018 Department of
Transportation signified by saying I I I
if you're opposed nay seeing none
carries
unanimously thank you thank you Mr B
we'll move on to item number 19 request
authorization to sell Brook Road or sell
to Brook Road management lrc
9,626 square feet uh 0 22 Acres state
owned Berlin Branch Railroad Corridor
town of Littleton for the recommended
sale price of
2,400 sir thank you the location of this
parcel is adjust adjacent to an
abandoned and unused railroad Corridor
uh the location included a u siding for
or a uh railroad customer that used to
occupy the property now owned by Brooks
management uh actually a Timber Warf had
been built on the railroad property for
that company to access railroad cars for
loading and unloading well without uh
need
for unloading railroad
cars the uh a butter asked to inquired
if they could purchase it because trees
and brush and stuff were growing up on
that land
and he would he wanted to maintain it
and we came to an agreement that would
be a better fit if we sold that
ancillary parcel which has no use for
through railroad uh to the abutter and
under his ownership he can uh cut the
trees uh brush mow the lawn so that's
why we recommend this sale thank you any
further questions to Department motion
by Eaton to approve second second by
Mills
um any further discussion seeing none if
you're in favor of the uh motion item
number 19 uh signified by saying I I any
opposed motion carries
unanimous we'll move to item 23
Department of Transportation approval to
enter into a one-year lease for East
Bluff Highland Association on East Bluff
Village Condominium Association for 58
ft of state owned Railroad frage along
Lake wiip pasak non-commercial
please yeah good again good morning
thank you for hearing this
uh the um the associations they have a
uh easement across property to the
railroad which uh was put in place by
grous point for just their you know
their individual access of uh to the uh
water um per statute RSA
228 colon 57
highy qualifies for a
do and we
have no issues with the occupation of
the land and a a grade crossing that
they installed and we've as to uh we
propose this lease and the reason it's
only one year is coming up on statutory
maturation of the current rate and uh we
felt it would be more appropriate to get
approve this and then we'll be back next
year with a five-year lease at the uh
rate that will be calculated per
statute thank you move to approve
2423 motion made ascenders and approved
or seconded if you're in favor of motion
um uh item number 23 signified by saying
I I any opposed motion Carri
shenan um item number 24 request to
enter a one-year lease uh Lake Ridge at
at Meredith Bay Association for 1351
feet of State on Railroad Frontage along
pgus
Bay um noncommercial with a pedestrian
at grade crossing state owned
um for a fee of
47,2
44.4 in the annual Crossing fee of $100
sir similar to the previous uh
proposal the multiple
owners have uh formed an
association to access uh the
Water they have requested an extensive
uh length of of the quarter so they
could have multip docks it benefits us
in a way that we only have to deal with
one Crossing so that's why we come with
this
one Proposal with the association rather
than multiples uh
requests
um they have been a good tenant
previously so we feel this is uh an
appropriate uh proposal and again we'll
be calcul ating in January a new rate
for long-term lease for the
statute thank you any questions move to
approve
2424 motion's been made second second by
Mills if you're in favor of item number
24 Department of Transportation
signified by saying I I any opposed
motion carries
unanimously uh I do not have anything on
miscellaneous for item four
informational is enclosed there and um
the next meeting will be at the call of
the chair we will try and go through
Sumer unless something comes up before
that uh any
questions motion to uh adjourn second
motion's been made second if you're in
favor of the motion signify by saying I